he looks so
like so cute yeah Pete Davidson just
made his on-camera debut on Hulu's the
Kardashians and he's coming in hot
people with some major tea revealing Kim
Kardashian shot him down the first time
he asked for her digits Kim and Pete may
have called it quits back in August
after nine months of dating but now fans
are getting a closer look at their time
together thanks to the famous family's
reality show
you guys ask for your number at the last
minute and you pretended that you
couldn't give it to me because you had
gloves on I know you asked me again this
time I don't have gloves on sure yep
that's Pete with the skims founder
leading up to their appearance at the
Met Ball in May the comedian recalling
how he initially tried to connect with
Kim at the same event a year earlier but
Kim she nicely turned him down I
remember being in the car being like wow
she knows how to like make someone feel
really good about themselves I was like
I thought that was really sweet oh you
think I'm sorry I can't give you I never
have gloves on I had only eight known
ET was with Kim just weeks before that
moment went down and she dished on what
makes Pete so special he's just super
genuine and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing Pete even had
Kim's famous family's seal of approval I
love that he's kind and really really
thoughtful he's the most thoughtful
person and I love the chemistry that Kim
and him have together it's really sweet
I thought you said the chemistry I was
like okay chemistry chemistry yeah and
that chemistry was on full display on
the Family's reality show babe yeah do
you want to shower with me really quick
[Laughter]
what just happened I'll tell you what
just happened Kim and Pete hit the
shower together why not Kim and Pete
made their red carpet debut two days
before they walked the Met stairs at the
White House correspondence dinner and
Pete admitted big glamorous public
events aren't really his thing
these things are a lot super stressful
and to do like three
or two back to back
two back to back was the killer we'll
never do the White House again super
wild I really wanted our first red
carpet for me to be in brown hair and
like I said I wanted it to be a
non-fashion event yeah I wanted us to be
getting slime with the Nickelodeon Kids
Choice of boys but you know
it's each of them and while the two
aren't a thing anymore a source recently
told E.T they still keep in touch quote
it wasn't a bad Fallout so things are
good between them totally fine now Pete
is making headlines with another famous
face model Emily radakowski with a
source-telling ET the pair runs in
similar circles and have known one
another for a while and the vibe between
them is flirtatious
[Music]
thank you